Jennifer drew Camila vaguely think the
attitude that defines a guest girl is
just being confident they've all been
guest girls there were always like these
very young beautiful new models that
call would break into the business and
really make famous but how exactly did
the whole guest girl thing get started
no my guess Carl while ET was there from
the beginning
the brand's signature black-and-white
ads date back more than 30 years and
featured one of the og supermodels
Claudia Schiffer oh sure not nobody's
perfect
maybe not but her first guest campaign
was pretty perfect capturing the world's
attention thanks to it throwback old
Hollywood vibes a short time I noticed
on the pictures afterwards that she had
that Brigitte Bardot resemblance and we
made her look even more like that if the
pictures came out and you know I was
like everybody was talking about it was
very surprising you didn't expect that
close we made after her welcoming
session change and it's just amazing and
if somebody says you look like worship I
don't I mean what can I say it's really
a nice compliment I adore her she's so
beautiful
I like black-and-white pictures a lot
and so did the rest of the world are you
know guest jeans okay
Levi's Wrangler what in the 90s most
famous guest girls was a little-known
model from Texas a in a name and a
Nicole Smith and today she's remembered
as the ultimate example of how guests
can make you an overnight success I was
just real real excited I mean I looked
so neat when they put all that makeup
and the hair and when it was all put
together it was just wow the brand
continue to seek out rising stars face
to white uh guess who branching out
beyond models to Hollywood it's always
been my dream to become a guest girl so
it was only natural when celebrities
began popping up in the brand's glitz
and glamor promotions gues approached me
and you know they made this very very
professional phone call and my response
was kicking and screaming on the kitchen
floor
you know the campaign received critical
acclaim not just for its famous faces
but also the storytelling found in each
photo it's not just like face I mean
there's something there's a story behind
it there's you know it's art it's really
exciting to see myself in this way it's
like a fantasy a fantasy sure but an
achievable one yes
is a great clothing line and it's
actually pretty affordable and something
that like you could wear every single
day you know it's the one thing on Rodeo
Drive that you'll see like I can wear
that school I can wear that to work you
know I don't know the clothes seem to
fit me well it's just fine it's quirky
it's you know now three decades in
guests continue to turn heads and make
fashion history with the black and white
guest girl ads and it's all thanks to
the company's first breakout star that
still has today's biggest stars wanting
to go gray
well grayscale you know those claudia
schiffer pictures look just as good now
as they did then and it's just as
striking if it did then and I feel like
conveying emotion or conveying a feeling
in a black-and-white picture I think
that's what makes it timeless so I think
that's what guess is to me it's sexy and
timeless
[Music]